- So happy Thursday everybody.
Welcome to the Data Science
Hangout. I hope
everyone's having a great week.
If we haven't met before,
I'm Rachael Dempsey.
I lead our community at Posit.
If this is your first time ever
joining us at a Data
Science
Hangout, welcome.
This is our open space
to chat about data science leadership,
questions you're facing,
and getting to hear about
what's going on in the world of
data across many
different industries and companies.
And so we're here
every Thursday,
except for July,
at the same time, same place.
So if you're watching
this recording on YouTube later,
you can also add these events to
your own calendar using the link below.
But together,
we're all dedicated to
making this a welcoming environment
for everyone. So we love
to hear from everybody,
no matter your level of experience,
the area of work or industry.
It is also totally OK to just listen
in and just hang out here with us.
There's also three ways you
can jump in and either ask
questions or provide your own
perspective on certain topics, too. So
you can always jump in
by raising your hand on Zoom,
and I'll keep an eye out.
You can put questions
in the Zoom chat.
And feel free to just put a
little star next to it if you
want me to read it
out loud instead,
if you're maybe in a
busy coffee shop or something.
And then, third--
we also have a Slido link
where you can ask questions
anonymously.
And I think Hannah or Curtis
will share that in the chat
here in just a second.
But I am so excited to
have my colleague Joe Cheng joining us
here today as our
featured leader.
Joe is the CTO and first
employee at Posit--
well, back then, RStudio
where he helped create the
RStudio IDE and Shiny web framework,
along with countless
complementary tools and packages.
And Joe,
I'd love to get things kicked
off here by having you also
introduce yourself and just
share a little bit about
your role and what it
means to be CTO at Posit.
- Yeah,
thanks for having me.
CTO
is actually an honorary title.
There are a lot of different
kinds of CTOs in the industry.
And
one of them is
basically an engineer
that joined very early,
and it's an honorary title.
And that's what it--
certainly it started
out as for me. It
started out as purely
an acknowledgment that
there are
strategic conversations that
the board and the executive team
would like me to be part of.
But my day to day was still
100% software engineer and then team lead.
And these days,
I think probably 90-plus
percent of my time is as a team
lead on the Shiny team.
It's a team of about 11. And
I,
every once in a while, will
do more CTO stuff,
which is having conversations that
are more at the strategic
level with the other execs
to talk about the direction that
we're taking the company in.
So for my day to
day, I try to do
50% coding and 50%
leading the team. That usually is
more like 15% coding and 85%
leading the team.
There's always emergencies and
last minute conversations
that come up.
So I do a lot of code
reviews. I do a ton of
helping to decide feature
directions. I do some talking
with customers. I
do some support.
Just really anything
that comes up.
And we try to run our team
that way, for the most part.
Most of our
roles are relatively
loose and flexible.
So we really value having
everyone on the team,
or certainly all the software
engineers to be really thoughtful about
what kind of features would be
interesting to add to Shiny to
be able to design their
own features to implement and
to be responsible for the quality
and support of their own features.
So yes, for me, it's
Shiny all the time--
Shiny day and nights,
Shiny for R, Shiny for
Python, packages that compliment Shiny,
HTML widgets.
For the last month,
I've been working on a--
sort of the equivalent
to the DT for R,
which is a way to
view data tables--
data frames and data tables
very quickly with a rich HTML
interface. I've been working
on that for Shiny for Python,
where we have not had that
capability in the past.
So that's one particular
feature that I've been working
on. But yeah, for sure,
most of my time is in
meetings and helping other team members
achieve what they need to.
- Thanks, Joe, and I forgot to
ask you this, but I usually ask everybody--
what's something that you like
to do outside of work, too?
- For me, that's cycling.
I don't do it nearly
as much as I'd like to,
but that's my favorite way to blow
off some steam after a long day.
- Perfect. Thank you.
So while we're waiting
for some questions
to come in from everybody here,
thank you so much for
the intro. And I'm wondering--
if somebody had never
heard about Shiny before,
how would you describe it?
- Yeah, so
to me,
Shiny is fundamentally about
letting data scientists create interactive
web applications to
take their analysis
that they're
already doing on their own
machine and taking the insights
that they are getting from
their data on their own machine
and being able to
expose that to--
usually other people,
sometimes to themselves,
but usually to expose that
to other people in a really
dynamic and interactive way.
In
the past, before Shiny, I think
you would see--
I mean,
it's still very common to issue
a static report and send it to
someone. And if there were
lots of variables in your analysis--
if there were lots of different
ways you might want to slice
and dice the data,
you would either just add more and
more pages to that PDF or HTML page.
And we had a lot of people tell
us that they would exchange
PDFs with thousands of pages,
and good luck trying to
find the page that you want.
Or you would do this
back and forth of, OK,
here's my best guess
at what you want,
and then you'd have this
endless email back and forth
of, how about this? How
about this? How about this,
until they find the needle in
the Haystack that they're looking for.
So
that's just one example of
when it might be useful to take
insights that you can easily
gain for yourself on your own
console, in your own notebook,
and to be able to
turn that into something that empowers
other people in your
organization or that you're
collaborating with,
or just that you think
might find your data interesting,
to be able to interact with that
data in a more dynamic and modern way.
That's how it started. That
and teaching statistics--
that was the other big
thing that we were very focused
on in the beginning. And
boy, it's been interesting
what people have taken
Shiny and used it for.
So in terms of what it's for--
everything from
BI to
machine learning and large
language models and games and
fantasy football
draft analyzers,
all sorts of interesting things
people have done with it.
But one of the most
important things for us
is that it is accessible
for anyone who calls themselves a
data scientist. So
you do need to code.
That is very important to us.
That's one of the core
tenets of our company,
is that we really
believe in code first.
But you don't have to be
able to code in web development technologies.
You don't need to be a web
developer to create Shiny apps.
You just need to be
conversant in the
language of data science.
- Thank you.
And I see an anonymous question
that came in a little bit ago,
which was, what's
the elevator pitch,
and then maybe further
discussion points,
for investing in Shiny,
rather than using
point-and-click BI tools?
- Yeah, absolutely,
that's a good question.
And it's interesting--
I had one thing in mind
when I created Shiny,
and then that has evolved
as I've gotten feedback from
people who have spent a lot of
time using both BI tools and Shiny.
So my elevator pitch in the
beginning was that BI tools are
great, and you should use Shiny
when those run out of steam.
In the beginning, that
was really about advanced analytics.
So if you want to just
draw some scatter plots and line charts--
I mean, BI tools can do a lot.
I'm not trying to be glib.
But if what you're trying to
do is completely within the
wheelhouse of BI tools, great.
No problem. Those
are awesome tools.
And
if you find yourself
wanting to use a predictive
model that they don't support--
and there are a lot that
they don't support--
or you want to pull from
some data source that is more
dynamic than a BI tool is
designed for, then use shiny. So it's--
for the simple stuff,
sure, use a BI tool--
I mean, if you can afford
it. A lot of them aren't cheap.
But then, for the
other stuff, use Shiny.
And I actually had a number
of people tell me that
it was actually not
like that for them--
that, in fact,
numerous times I've heard people
have to deploy to BI
tools within
their organization, or,
if they're consultants
and they're at a client,
that the only deployment target they
can feasibly use is, say, Tableau,
they would actually build it in
Shiny first and then import it
to Tableau. And I was like,
you're going to have to explain
to me why you're doing that.
That is very surprising.
And
what they said to me was that
a number of the advantages of
just using code in the first place
were just such big advantages
that they didn't want to give
them up when they
were using Tableau.
So first of all, it was
very common, they would say,
for them to work really hard
and come up with this very
sophisticated Tableau
application and then--
or Tableau dashboard.
And then the stakeholder would
say, oh, that looks great.
Please just change this or that
thing and this or that thing.
Because of the way these
point-and-click tools work,
you would have to start
the whole thing over. I mean,
you would have all the insights
you gained along the way,
but the mechanics
of building it--
you would have to build
it again from scratch, whereas
for a Shiny app, you could
just replace a single line to
use a different data source.
Or
sometimes they would
be like, that's great,
and we want the same dashboard
now for these 10 other departments--
these 10 other
scenarios. And again,
you'd be in this position of--
the reuse was really a
lot harder than when you were
dealing with code.
So that was one.
The second people
told me was that the
extensibility was really
frustrating for them.
To build
a BI dashboard that serves
you well for a while,
but then to know that there
is always the possibility of some
new requirement arriving that
they would not be able to
satisfy, whereas Shiny having
a ceiling that's essentially--
by comparison, it's infinite--
was very comforting to them.
And the third is that--
the
feedback I received was that,
if you know how to code,
that doing a Shiny dashboard
in code is just more fun than
the point and
click, especially--
when you know what you want to do
and you know how you would code it,
it's frustrating to try
to figure out how the
point-and-click interface
wants you to express that.
And then, finally,
just being pragmatic, people
told me that it's
a better resume builder to have
built a bunch of Shiny apps
than to have built
a bunch of Tableau
point-and-click dashboards,
that had led them to better
career opportunities.
I'm just being
real with you guys.
That's not something like
we put on the website,
but I've heard
that too many times
to think that that's not a real
motivation for some people.
Shiny, because we're all
control freaks. Totally, Luke.
- [LAUGHS]
Joe,
a few people are commenting that
was a very long elevator ride.
- Yeah, I tend to do that.
- [LAUGHS]
No, that was great
though, Thank you so much.
Ethan, I see you had asked
a question in the Zoom chat.
Do you want to jump in here?
- Yeah, sure, hi, Joe.
I actually haven't tried
Shiny Python yet,
but just want to get
you some high-level thoughts when you're
developing Shiny Python.
Is anything that you've learned
from developing it for offers?
And then
in terms of feature parity, is
it a asset or liability for the
engineering team when
developing Shiny for Python?
- Yeah, very good questions.
I'd say one of the biggest
things we learned--
I'll say there's
two main things that
come to mind when thinking
about the process of developing
Shiny for Python.
One--
well, I'd say this isn't
something I learned,
but definitely some other
people on the team learned--
jumping to Python
was not as scary as it sounded.
I think, for a lot of people
that were on my team, R--
and JavaScript but mostly R
was the language that they learned
to program in and have
invested many, many, many years
of their lives and careers in.
And
there was a lot of
assumption, in the beginning,
that we ware going to have
to hire a bunch of Python experts.
And
I don't want to be--
I don't want to
oversimplify it because
I think it is not true that
you can just pick up a book and
learn Python really
well in just a few days.
You really need to spend
time with the language
to learn beyond
just the syntax,
learn the true Pythonic
way to do things,
and that takes some time.
But when you are working full
time on a project with a bunch
of team members that are
going through the same thing,
it actually did not
take very long for our
devs to be quite productive in
Python. So that was one thing,
is that on a technical--
on the technical side,
it was not really a very
difficult transition for the
team to become bilingual.
And I think the second
thing is that in Python--
this might not be that
interesting for data science.
But for software engineering,
Python, in recent versions,
has gotten better and better at
static type checking,
so the ability to mark up
your variables and function
arguments with not only the name
of a parameter but the type
that you expect it to be,
and then having tools that will
analyze your code and make
sure that every function is being
called in an appropriate way.
Those tools, I think,
are mostly seen these days as
a liability in data science that,
they slow you down because you
have to write this extra code.
But when you are building
something like Shiny,
it's a huge help. And
that's one of the
things that I think--
coming away from
shipping the first versions of
Shiny for Python, it's
ah,
it would have been really nice
if we could have these same tools
on the R side to
help us maintain Shiny for R.
Sorry. Can you remind me?
What was the second
part of your question?
- Yeah, it's about
feature parity.
Do you see that as an
asset or liability for your engineering team?
- Yeah. So
do you mean feature parity
between R and Python in general,
or trying to achieve feature
parity between Shiny for R and
Shiny for Python?
- Shiny in specific.
- Oh, OK, yeah. So
I think it is definitely
a double-edged sword.
It's super helpful to have
built all this once before
because so many problems--
we
not only have a solution for,
but we thought about multiple
solutions before we decided on
one. And we can go
back and reanalyze very quickly
without having to invent
too much stuff
from whole cloth.
But
the tough thing, I think,
is that sometimes we
are a little bit--
we try not to,
but we feel a little bit
stuck with the decisions that we've
made in the past.
So the biggest one that we've
been discussing to death--
sorry, we've been discussing--
is--
Shiny modules is a feature
for Shiny for R where,
if you want to--
if your app is
getting too complex--
there's too much stuff going on
in one server function or one
UI, you can break
it up into modules.
And those modules
can be reused.
They're name spaced.
It really helps you reason
about your app as a collection
of smaller pieces.
In Python, we have
that feature as well.
It's also called
Shiny Modules. Well,
Python modules are a thing
in Python, and the name, modules--
for us to move away
from that for Python,
it means now we have two.
There are Shiny modules for R,
and then there are
Python components
for Shiny for Python. And that
is super annoying for all of us.
So I think there are a lot
of little things like this,
where we feel a little bit
beholden to the past because it
would be awkward to
have different versions,
but at the same time,
doesn't necessarily always fit 100%.
It hasn't been that bad, but
the times when it comes up,
it certainly is frustrating.
- Thank you. It's
a good perspective.
- Libby, I see you had
a question in the chat.
Do you want to jump in here?
- Sure,
can you hear me? My
mic's been acting up.
- Sounds good.
- You can, OK.
My question is--
if you could go back in time
to 15 years ago,
20 years ago and tell
yourself what you're doing right now--
what your career looks,
what your life looks like,
what do you think would
surprise your younger self the most?
- Everything, everything.
- [LAUGHS]
- I've been unbelievably
fortunate in not only my career
but in my family life and
my relationship with my extended family.
My life has--
yeah, it's been an incredible
run. And I think there were
a set of things that I
really wanted to accomplish by the end
of my career, and
I don't know--
I sort of find myself
in my mid-forties
needing to cast a
new vision because
all the things that I wanted to
do I have just had the great
privilege and been so fortunate
as to have those things
happen to me in my career.
And I think, in particular,
15 years ago in my
career, I felt like
I had stumbled into
this incredible industry--
just talking about
tech in general,
that, back then, had
a very different feel.
It felt like we were--
it was not quite as mainstream, and
I felt like I had stumbled into this--
I mean, so fun--
like, such a fun way
to make a living,
to be writing
programs all day with
smart and interesting people, and
to feel like I had
all my natural
talents aligned with
the skills and interests
you need to be in software.
And the thing that scared
me 15 years ago was--
what if all of my career
contributions, through luck or
happenstance, add up to not
very much? That was my fear,
was that I have the
education for this.
I have the natural talent
for this. I have the opportunity.
But there's so
much luck involved.
Will I get the opportunity
to actually do something that is
interesting and meaningful?
And
when I was working on RStudio,
I was already feeling like, oh,
wow, this could really be
it. And then Shiny felt
like, OK, this is overdoing it a
little bit. But I mean, it was--
like I never had--
I never pictured myself
coming up with a truly--
I was going to say,
truly original idea.
The idea is 99% building on the
shoulders of reactive work
that was done in JavaScript.
But even like the insight to apply
it in this new way on the
server side to data science--
I never aspired to have
an idea like that. I just
aspired for somebody
else to have an idea,
and I would be able to help,
and for it to be really
impactful. So
in our little corner of
the world that is data science,
Shiny has had a bigger impact than I
was ever hoping for out of my career.
So I think that would be
the most comforting thing for me, 15
years ago, to find out it's not
all going to add up to nothing.
There is going to be some
good that comes out of the stuff
that you do, that
these ideas are going to
impact people's work and impact
the design of other packages
that have been created,
both in R and in Python. So
I'm just super, super grateful
for that because that was--
like, it was really
something that I was very,
very anxious about, that it
would all add up to nothing.
Oh, this got a little bit real.
- Thank you. I don't think
you have to worry anymore,
about that concern. You're good.
- Thank you, Joe.
And I saw it--
and thank you for the question
Libby. I see Lisa said,
please answer this without making
us tear up again like
you did at Conf.
[LAUGHS]
And it was just reminding me--
I love listening to
you present, Joe,
and how you tell stories and
how you can be vulnerable and
put emotion into your presentations.
And I was just wondering--
how
do you learn that?
How did you learn how to get
up on stage and make us feel all
those emotions that we all
did at the RStudio conference?
- It's
funny. I can tell you exactly
how it happened. I mean,
I'd given a lot of
presentations before that one,
but that was the first
one that I was like,
what if I made this
90% about the
technology but 10%
share something that
cost me a little bit?
And
it was actually because I
attend a local church,
and
there was this
pastor who got up--
he and his wife--
and they, in front of
all these people and being livestreamed,
talked about how he had cheated on
her in the first year of their marriage.
And I mean, it had been--
I don't know--
20, 30 years. But still,
that the two of them would
get up and talk about
the most painful thing,
the most painful betrayal that
he ever inflicted on her--
that they would both get
up and talk about it--
I was like, holy crap.
The courage that it takes to do that.
And
I just got so much value out
of that because who shares
that kind of stuff in
a live, in person?
So I'm not trying to
compare me saying, oh,
I was feeling a little bit
bad about my career to that.
But I was thinking
this energy
is so--
like, it was so meaningful.
It was such a beautiful
moment, and there was just no
pure head insight
that could compare.
And
it made me feel close to them,
that they were sharing something
that was so close to their--
I don't know--
so vulnerable.
So yeah, I brought it up
with my speaking coach,
and she was a little bit like,
wait, why are you going to
do this? And I was like,
I don't know. I just
really love this community.
And I feel like whenever
we--
the best parts of this
community are not--
it's not about the
technical exchange. It's--
when we do have those opportunities
to get real with each other,
like when people talk about
imposter syndrome from the stage,
those are some of the most
powerful moments. And I felt like
what if I did that for
a keynote? Because that story is true.
That
was not something I
had to conjure up.
I think about that
moment all the time.
Oh, and actually, I have
to give credit to Jesse Mostipak.
I told that story to her.
And she was like, get out
of town. As soon as you said
that was supposed to be my last
day at RStudio, I was like,
tell me the rest of this
story. So she really--
I have to give her, I think,
most of the credit for recognizing
that story was one of those--
it could be one
of those moments.
- Well, thank you, Joe.
It feels like there's not
really a natural transition for
me to go from this
emotional conversation to jumping back
into technical, but we're
just going to do it. So
thank you, Joe.
I see that there are few
questions earlier in the chat I
want to get to. But Dan,
I see you put a question in
there about how you're starting
to develop in Shiny,
coming from Python.
Do you want to jump
in here with that?
DAN: Yeah, sure,
Rachel. Hi, Joe.
I am
more of a Python developer,
although I started
years and years ago,
many blue moons ago with and
really fell in love with it,
and coming back to it a
little bit and trying to develop with
Shiny. One frustration I
have is just around debugging
and when you've got all
these panes and windows
and UI widgets.
Can you share your
thoughts around--
or best practices,
tips, whatever,
on the best way to go through
the debugging process?
- Yeah, absolutely. And
can you just clarify--
when you say, debugging, you
mean in a more general sense,
not just using an
interactive debugger?
DAN: Yeah, correct. Like, I do
everything in RStudio at the moment.
And I run the app.
All of a sudden,
it just opens up
and then closes.
Or I run something--
it spools an error, and
it's not always obvious
where the error actually is.
It could be in the output side.
It could be on the server side.
And just maybe the pattern for
debugging in R Shiny's just so
different from
what I'm used to--
that could be it, too.
- Yeah, it absolutely is well,
especially if your
work on Python--
was it around
notebooks and scripts?
DAN: Yeah, you got
it. Yeah, Jupyter Notebooks, scripts,
that kind of thing.
- Yeah, absolutely.
So I think--
for those of you who do
not use Shiny especially,
when you were doing
normal analysis with a notebook
or a script on your desktop,
your code generally executes
from beginning to end, right?
Like, you might
have some functions,
but those functions are
called when you call them.
And you have loops, but
they loop when you loop.
It's very transparent where
the interpreter is
at any given moment.
With Shiny and
almost every other form
of interactive framework,
you provide
code to the framework,
and the framework
decides when it executes.
So it makes it much
less intuitive to debug because--
like, OK, this code is
executing. Why is it executing?
How did it get here?
It's much less transparent
when code is executing,
why it's executing.
So there's a couple of things
that I'll tell you from
a debugging perspective. Number one,
I think that Hadley's book
Mastering Shiny
has a chapter on this.
And we definitely have at least
a couple of video resources
where we've given
talks about this.
So I'd highly recommend
those. But I have a couple of
principles that I always
go back to is as well.
Number one--
and maybe
this less applies to you
if you're coming from Python, but
stack traces are
very important.
Often when you get
an error in Shiny,
you get a big bunch of
lines spit out at the console that
say, from this file,
this function name--
from this file, this
function name, this file,
this function name. And they
often are multiple line.
And often people find
that scary because
a lot of the function names
that are in there are function
names that they might not
recognize because it's not code
that they wrote that's
executing it's code that's
inside of a package that's
calling base R.
DAN: Exactly, yeah.
- Yeah, so it's very important
to not be afraid of
that stack trace.
It is very important to take
the time to learn how to read
those and understand
exactly what's going on.
And what the stack trace is
telling you is that at the
moment that this
error occurred,
what were the functions, in
order, that had been called?
So if you think about--
at any given moment, when
code is executing for R--
that code is probably
in a function,
and that function was
called by another function.
And that call was called
by another function, and that call--
and so on and so forth, and
it could be 20 levels deep.
That is called your call stack, and
when an error occurs,
one of the most useful things
to know is what was the call
stack. And when that's
printed to the console,
now it's called a stack trace.
So you can take
that stack trace,
and you can read up it and
just ignore the lines that you don't
recognize and find the line
that you do recognize that
says, this was
the line of code.
In your app.R file, it was line
49. That was the thing that was
executing when this error
happened. And I think that--
for the easy cases where,
let's say, I don't know--
you used the wrong function
name or you indexed
into a data frame
using an invalid
variable or
something like that--
just understanding
the stack trace--
that
will be enough for you to
fix the problem. So that's one.
The second thing you can
do that's super useful is--
especially in Shiny--
never forget that there is
a JavaScript console, also,
that might be printing
errors. And this is--
I feel really bad about this.
We should do things in
Shiny to surface this more prominently.
But when you're in your browser
looking at your Shiny app,
if things are not behaving the
way you expect and you don't
see any errors
in the R console,
you can show the JavaScript
console in your browser.
And if you see a
bunch of errors there,
that's a big clue
for you as well.
Often,
that means there's some kind of
bug in a component that you're using,
whether it's in Shiny or some
kind of third party components. But
if
you're raising a GitHub
issue or whatever,
that's some of the most
useful information you can provide.
The third--
and I'll move on after this--
is to--
so Shiny does demand that you
write your code in a certain
way. We have reactive outputs
and reactive expressions,
and you have to put your code
in a certain place to get it to
execute at the right time.
That doesn't mean that your
data science logic--
that your data analysis,
your data manipulation,
and your visualization--
that logic doesn't
have to live there.
You can write functions
that live off to the side.
They can even live in
a separate function.
a package, if you want.
So you can write functions that
are not Shiny. They're just R functions
that
perform the tasks that you
want, and you call them from
Shiny. You call them
from your Shiny outputs.
And the advantage of
doing it this way is that,
if something goes wrong,
you can test these pieces
in isolation from the console.
So you can make sure that
each of these functions that you
create, that do your
data manipulation,
that do your data
visualization--
you can ensure that they
are working correctly.
And then your Shiny
app collapses to just--
a very small number
of lines of code,
and then it's much easier
to reason about when things are
being called and why.
DAN: Yeah, that's helpful.
I've been using the Breakpoints
and Browser and things like that
a little bit, but it's still--
just compared to
what I'm used to--
a different mental model.
But I think what you laid
out is helpful, so thank you.
- Yeah, the
Browser and Breakpoints are super
helpful when you need them. But
like, on my team I'm
constantly using the phrase,
can you reason
about it? I mean,
they must be so sick
of me saying that,
but when you write code, it
is not enough that it works.
If it's important
for it to be right,
it's not enough that it works.
You have to be able
to reason about it.
And I find Browser is the
most helpful when you have lost the
ability to reason
about your code.
So definitely use it but
also think to yourself, like,
if this was really the only way
for me to figure out what was
going on, maybe it's time to
refactor my code a little bit, also.
Oh, great.
Libby Heeren said, I loved
Tan Ho's little blurb.
Functions contain LogicModules.
Call those functions app.R
calls and modules. That's great.
- Yeah,
there's a lot of great links and
resources being shared in the chat, too.
Yeah, just to remind everybody
you can save the chat, too.
So those little buttons
below that say More--
you could save those
links there, too.
Joe, so another question--
oh, Sam, I see you had a
question in the chat earlier.
Do you want to jump in here?
SAM: Yeah, sure.
Can you hear me?
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: Yeah.
- OK,
so I just had a question
regarding the various
development frameworks and what
your thoughts are [INAUDIBLE]
the development frameworks
like 'golem,' for RInno,
from production-grade
development.
Has Posit considered releasing their
own framework once upon a time
before the [INAUDIBLE]
release?
- Yeah, the question is--
if you guys are not familiar,
there are a couple of packages
that have been created
to provide more opinionated structure
around how Shiny apps are written.
So 'golem' and RInno
are probably the two--
by far, the two most popular.
I have to say--
I'm a little embarrassed. Like,
this is a very important topic,
and I know people have
really strong opinions about this.
And in particular, I
think 'golem' has huge
proponents among people
that I know and respect.
I
personally have not
spent that much time
with these
frameworks. I think--
just the tradition that I
come from in my background in
software engineering--
I feel like a lot of people--
sorry, this is not the
only reason people use these frameworks.
But I do think that part of--
one thing that I've noticed
that people really like in a
lot of parts of
data science is--
especially if you didn't set
out to become a programmer but
accidentally became
a programmer,
I think a lot of
people feel like,
if they're doing what
it says in the tutorial,
if they're doing what it says
in an article that Hadley
wrote, then they're
doing it right.
And if they're doing something
that they invented or a pattern
that they just came
up with, then, ah,
that's a hack, or that's
a workaround or whatever.
So I've had a lot of
people ask me things
on the Shiny issues or
Shiny forums and say,
hey, how do I
solve this problem?
Or it would be great if
you had this feature.
I solved it this way, but it
would be nice to have it for
real. And it's like--
the way you did it is perfect.
What about this solution
does not satisfy you?
And they're like, yeah,
well, but I did it,
so I would really like
a grown up to do it.
And
I think, in the beginning,
it felt like a lot of
people were looking for a lot more
guidance for how to structure
their Shiny apps, and 'golem' provided
a set of opinions--
that people could look to
Vincent and Colin and
say, those people are clearly
experts. If I use 'golem,' then
I'm allowed to do that,
whereas I had much more
of an attitude of--
it's R,
so you should feel free to
package these things however you want,
and you don't need anybody to
tell you that that's OK or not.
I do totally reserve
the right to judge you,
but you should do it anyway.
So
I think, over the
years, though, it has--
more and more
people have told me
it is not just about that.
It's not just a set of opinions
that are nice to have--
that they actually
do try to provide a
lower friction environment for you
to do development and have
been very thoughtful about how you
run and reload your app. And
I totally believe
that it has value.
I have to admit,
I have underinvested in
spending time with those.
But I certainly--
certainly, I expect those
things to work well given how
much people use them.
- To go back to the
question right before this,
there was a follow-up
question about--
could you say a little bit
more about what you mean by,
can you reason about it?
I think it might be
helpful for us all, yeah.
- My favorite topic.
Yeah, so
I think--
just to reiterate--
when you write software or
do an analysis or whatever,
there's a level of--
I got it to work.
And then there's the level of--
it works, and I can
reason about it.
And what that
means is software--
complex pieces of software
are among the most complicated
things that humankind
has ever devised.
What other human-made
constructs can have
hundreds of millions of pieces
and yet they're expected to all
fit and work together so
precisely that, if one token is
off, rockets
explode and
you get the wrong answers?
And
I don't know what
the limit is, but
even the smartest humans--
there is some small number of
variables you can hold in your head.
There's a small number of
operations that you can hold in
your head at any one time.
So
when we work on software
that's non-trivial,
when we work on software that,
in its totality, is more
than the human mind--
more than any one human mind
can hold at any one given time,
the main challenge in
software engineering is about,
how do you take all this
complexity and break it down
into smaller pieces, each of
which you can reason about,
each of which you can
hold in your head,
look at and be like,
yeah, I can fully--
I can fully ingest this entire
function definition. I can read it,
line by line, and
prove to myself,
this is definitely correct if
the functions that it's calling
don't have bugs and if it's
called in the right way.
So with those caveats,
if the things that this thing
is calling are correct and I'm
called correctly,
then the result will be correct
because the logic here is correct.
So
software engineering, at all
but the most beginner level,
is a lot about this. How
do you break up inherently
complicated things that we're trying
to do into small pieces
that are individually
easy to reason about ?
And that's half the
battle right there.
The other half
of the battle is,
how do we combine them in ways
that can be reliable and also easy to
reason about?
So
it's these two pieces--
small pieces
reliably composed--
if you can achieve that,
that's what I'm talking about.
That's software that
you can reason about.
So
this has implications for data science as
well. When you have a data science,
you're doing some kind
of analysis on some data,
and it starts out as, oh,
I'm just doing these simple things.
I'm doing this manipulation,
and then I'm doing
this visualization.
But then as you get
deeper and deeper into it,
it grows and grows
and grows and grows.
And you're at the point
where you're at the end,
and you don't remember
where these variables came from.
You don't remember
what's the difference between this
data frame and this data
frame. And you go back and
hopefully start breaking it
into functions or somehow
dividing it into smaller pieces
that each focus on a thing.
And then you join those
pieces together in your overall script.
So that is--
that's this principle of
small pieces individually
able to be reasoned about. And
when you think about other
rules that you might have heard
about software
engineering, we know,
when you're writing functions,
using global variables is bad.
That's another one of these
things where that hurts your
ability to hold the entire
function in your head and to
prove that it'll work correctly
because who knows who's setting
that global variable
to what value?
So you can't prove to
yourself this function is definitely correct.
So
I think--
if there's anything that you're working
on that needs to be correct--
if you're just zipping off some
analysis and it really doesn't matter.
You just a pretty picture
or something like that or
whatever. I don't know
what that situation is.
But if you don't care if
the answer is right, sure.
But if you do care that
the answer is right,
I try never to stop when I have
an answer but I can't
reason about the code.
I always try to go back and
do the refactoring that's
necessary just so I can prove to
myself that the answer is right. Oh,
and the other big benefit to
this is that those individual pieces--
if it does turn out that
there's a mistakes somewhere,
you can individually
debug, test,
unit test those
individual pieces.
And when there are problems,
you'll much more easily
be able to find them.
- Great. Thank you. So I see
an anonymous question that
touches on what you've asked as
well, Alan, so I'm going to
ask you to jump in here, too,
first, with your question.
- Yeah, sure, thanks.
Hi, Joe, I'm really
curious about--
you mentioned earlier that you and the
team had to think a lot about--
and you were nervous about--
how do we learn Python?
How do we learn what we need
to know here to do Shiny for Python?
I'm really curious--
now that it's--
you're trying to gain momentum with
it, trying to establish it, et cetera,
have you had to come up
with a different way to approach the
Python community than maybe you would have
taken for granted in the R community?
We know that community has changed
so much over 15, 20 years.
What's it like to come into
the Python community now,
and how did that feel? What
was successful? Was it hard?
Curious how you come
into that space.
- It is 1,000% different. It
is completely and utterly different. And
it's
hard to enumerate how
many differences that there are
because there are so many. But
the biggest, by far, is that--
I mean, Python is
just such a noisy
space. Well,
that's a really uncharitable word. It's
a very vibrant and active space.
I think, in the early days
of RStudio, the company,
there
was a lot of
interest in activity around R,
but
it was not like
Python is today.
Python--
you
can't think of any niche and not
find 15 packages that do that thing,
and there are two more
venture-backed ones coming out next week.
It's just--
the level of activity is
on such a different level. And
it's quite--
it was quite a wake-up
call to come into that,
going to conferences and things like
that, and realizing, OK, not only
are we not a well-known
entity in the Python world,
especially after we
rebranded the company. But
like the amount that you would
have to scream to get over this
noise is just incredible.
So that was one big takeaway,
is that we really don't have
the luxury of being heard
or taking for granted that
we're going to be heard with
any particular
message that we have.
And that makes it so much more
important that when we tell our story,
that we know exactly who we're
telling it to and that we know
exactly what's going to
resonate with them because I
think, in the R community,
when Shiny came out,
people were willing to
spend the time to find out,
does this really
make sense for me?
And they were willing
to do some work.
And
for Python,
there's 15 other options, so why would you--
and there are so many very--
I think,
because it's such a big
community and there's so much--
at least it's perceived that
there's so much money to be
made, being content
creators for this community,
or whatever other reasons people
have for doing content creation--
I've heard that there is a
content treadmill that people
get on that adds to the
noise, where it's like,
in order for the algorithm
to take me seriously,
I have to create a new
Python
package shoot-out every--
twice a week. And you can
only do so much research
in three days, so you
end up with just--
this incredible volume
of very shallow noise.
And that's just not something I
ever remember being a big part
of the community.
And I know it's--
for Python users, it's both
a blessing and a curse.
It's awesome to know that
whatever it is that you want to
solve, somebody is out there
with either a free or
paid solution for you.
But now the work is figuring
out which makes sense,
and a lot of the analysis out
there is not going to be too helpful.
I will say, though,
that in terms of the people
that I've met in the community,
there are two really
big takeaways that I have--
number one--
that almost everybody
that I've met has been
very kind and generous
to talk with us and
pretty nice. And
I don't know--
I had heard people in
the R community say,
I have been in the Python
community, and boy,
it's so refreshing to
be here and whatever.
And
at least the particular
conferences that I've been to,
and being 2022 or 2023--
I don't know how it
was 10 years ago. But yeah,
I really saw a lot of the
same things that I like in the R
community happening in
the Python community,
maybe without the slightly more tightly
knit feeling that comes from
being a small community
for so many years.
But the other thing is that
it's such a big community that
I feel like it is very,
very hard to generalize what people--
what a Python data
scientist even is.
It's hard to even divide
it into four or five groups.
There's so much diversity.
There are people who
are like so much more
commercial than the average R
user is, who are so
much more focused on--
this
is a purely commercial interest
for them, to people who
are so much more extreme
free software zealots than I have
ever met. And that's
coming from someone who obviously
really, really believes
in open source software.
I had a couple people ask
us at PyData Seattle--
so you have all this open
source stuff, but you also have
these complimentary
commercial offerings.
To me, you don't
count as open source.
It's like, what?
Or people who say,
because your governance model is
not open and you don't have
a democratically elected board, you're
not open source. I'm like--
[LAUGHS]
Cool that you have that
position. Totally respect that.
But to say that, open source,
is the word that means
the thing that I like--
I'm like, wow,
this is not something that I
have ever encountered in the R
world. So again,
the whole spectrum
has been represented at each
of the conferences I've been to.
And I guess I was a little
bit surprised that it is not just
such a big community but so
incredibly diverse.
- Awesome. Thank you. I
appreciate hearing all of that
so much. Really, really
grateful for your thoughts on
that. Thanks, Joe.
- Thanks, Joe. I see
there was an anonymous question from--
actually, towards
the beginning--
I want to make sure I get
to as well. And it was,
I get questions from it and
leadership about data security with Shiny apps.
What training or tools do you
recommend for testing our Shiny apps--
for example, like, pen test?
- Yeah,
that is a really good question.
I used to have good answers
for this because we would receive
the pen test
reports from people.
And I will say
two things about those
pen tests. I think,
one, I was surprised how well
those
pen test tools
worked against Shiny,
in the sense that the
tools didn't break. Like,
they did actually run their
tests and treat Shiny as no
different than any other web
app that they would test.
So that was cool to see,
and there were results that,
once in a blue moon, would
actually be relevant.
But on the other hand, I think,
in my experience, the
false positive ratio to
true security issue--
that ratio is--
it's really surprisingly noisy,
and
noisy in a scary way because
they sound very, very
plausible. These reports come
back, and they sound
very, very plausible.
But like nine times out of 10,
they're just using heuristics
and don't really understand
what the parameters they are
looking at and what value they
have. So I would say, if
your organization says to use them,
I would expect whatever pen
test whatever web-based pen test tool
that you're using to work.
But
if you have red flags come up,
expect to have to go
through our support
and talk it through with them.
In terms of actually
improving your security,
I think a higher value
thing is to read the--
there's a very standard--
I think OWASP is the acronym--
O-W-A-S-P--
the Open Web Application
Security Project or something
like that? And they have an
ever evolving list of the top
10 vulnerabilities,
classes of vulnerabilities
you need to worry about
when you're building
your web applications.
And I found those to be
consistently excellent advice.
Every one of those
vulnerabilities is one you
should at least be aware of.
And
if you're a more
experienced Shiny developer,
hopefully you should be able to at least
be able to connect the
dots between how they're expressing
the problem and how that
might affect your Shiny app. Like,
code injection is one example,
where you take a
parameter from a user--
and the classic one is you
just take whatever name they typed
in, and you just
glom that onto the end of a
SQL query string that you have
and put like quotes around it.
But
that input is coming
from the user.
They could put
a single quote in their
input, and that would
finish your string.
And now their input is being
interpreted as SQL code.
There's a famous
xkcd about this.
If you google for Bobby Tables
you'll find it. So
that's an example
of a SQL injection.
That's totally something
that, if you weren't paying
attention, you could
introduce into a Shiny app.
You could form a SQL query
that you're about to send to
Oracle or PostgreSQL and add user
input to the end so there
are things that you need to do
to not do that. So for sure,
run the pen test if your
organization does that. But I
think, more important,
read through the OWASP
list of vulnerabilities.
- Thank you, Joe.
I see that we have gone to
the top of the hour very quickly.
This might be a record for
how fast this time is going by.
But I see a lot of people
saying, thank you so much, Joe.
And Javier just said,
Shiny single-handedly changed the
trajectory of my career,
so thank you so much.
- Oh, that's so nice.
- Something I wanted to
ask you, before we go, is,
what's something that you're most
excited about as you think
about the year ahead?
I
think there's a lot of things to
be excited about for Posit, the company.
Oh, actually--
I'm going to start
with my team,
but it applies to
the company as well.
I'm really excited about some
of the people that we have
added to the team over
the last few months.
And
any time you hire someone, it's--
at least for me, I really feel like
you never
know how it's going to
go, and it can really
improve or
hurt the team.
And I'm really excited about
the people that we've added
lately and really excited to
see where they help the entire
team move over the next year.
And I think--
actually, thinking about it--
that's true for Posit
as well. I think some
of the people we've added over the
last year have the potential to be,
really, the right
people to help us get to
the next level as a company.
So yeah, the people--
wow, that's very original, but
I'm excited about the people. [LAUGHS]
-
Was there anything that you actually
wanted to ask us all here?
I put you on the spot for
that. I didn't as you that before.
- I'm in
question-answering mode.
I think if we had more
time, yeah I would love--
and I'll say I
have really enjoyed
the times when I get
to lurk in these Data Science
Hangouts. I certainly learn a
lot from you all. The
discipline of building
the software that we build is
so different from the using of
it that you all do. And
we always want to be guided
by the actual stuff that everybody
is out there doing.
So yeah,
so I'm always happy to just lurk
and hear what you all are up to.
- Well, we love that
you join us here on the
Hangouts, too.
Just want to say,
thank you again,
Joe, for sharing your experience
and guidance with us all here.
And thank you all for joining
today and all the great questions.
I didn't want to forget to say
again that we will be on a bit
of a break for July. We'll
be back on Thursday, August 3.
We were just chatting a little
bit in the Zoom chat about
maybe having a little
summer book club, and
Subtract is a book
that just keeps coming up.
I know Libby's really
excited about that book.
So I can
post more about that
in our Data Science
Hangout
LinkedIn group, too.
But if anybody is interested in joining that--
but thank you all so much
for making the hangout what it is
and being here with us today.
Have a great few weeks,
and I'll see you in August.